There's a new wave of Android Wear watches coming out this fall,...
...and they're gonna have a new trick.
They're gonna work with the iPhone,...
...that means the Apple watch is gonna have a lot more competition pretty soon.
But the big question is,...
...how much can Google's watches do when they're paired with iOS?
We went to Google's Headquarters to find out.
So today, we're announcing that we're bringing Android Wear to iOS.
So if you have an iPhone, you can also use these watches.
I actually got a chance to set up Android wear with my own iPhone,...
...and the setup was actually really simple.
You just download the Android Wear app from the App Store, install it on your phone,...
...pair it with an Android Wear watch and you're done.
But Google can't dig down deep into the bones of iOS the way that the Apple watch can...
...and that introduces some complications.
Google actually manage to work around a lot of them especially with notifications,...
...but the problem is, there are few things that the Android Wear app...
...just can't do with iOS.
At launch, Android Wear is only gonna work for few watches with the iPhone.
The Huawei Watch, the Asus Zen Watch 2, and the LG Watch Urbane.
But a lot more are coming very, very soon.
And that's gonna mean a lot of competition for the Apple watch.
They might not be able to match it on features but they can definitely be competitive...
...on the numbers of styles and on price.